هولندي اصيب بالشلل جراء حادث في الصين
عام 2011
عاد ليقف على قدميه بفضل تكنولوجيا طورها
علماء السويسريون من مستشفى منطقه فول
جامعي ومعهد علمي عريق وهو مدرسه لوزان
الفيدراليه للعلوم التطبيقيه
في غضون 50 الى عشر دقائق تمكنت من التحكم
في الوركين مثل ما التقطت الشريحه
الدماغيه ما كنت افعله لذا كانت هذه افضل
نتيجه
العلم يعطي املا لذوي الاحتياجات خاصه
الذين تعرضوا لحوادث اثرت على جهازهم
العصبي
للمشي يجب ان يرسل الدماغ امرا الى منطقه
النخاع الشوكي المسؤوله عن التحكم في
الحركات عندما تكون اصابه في النخاع
الشوكي يتم قطع هذا الاتصال كانت فكرتنا
اعاده انشاء هذا الاتصال بجسر رقمي وهو
اتصال الكتروني بين الدماغ ومنطقه الحبل
الشوكي التي لا تزال سليمه ويمكنها التحكم
في حركه الساق
الجراحه التي اجريت لجيرتيان تتلخص في
زراعه شريحتين في الدماغ تسمحان بارسال
اشارات عصبيه الكترونيه لاطراف الجسم
والتحدي الذي يواجهه الشاب الهولندي الان
هو تعويد عضلات جسمه وجهازه العصبي الهش
على المشي ورغم هذا الانجاز العلمي الكبير
الا انه ما زال امام
وغيره من ذوي الاحتياجات الخاصه طريق طويل
قبل ان يصبح هذا الجهاز متوفرا خارج نطاق
المعاهد العلميه انس نماسي العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات